welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Watson guardians of the galaxy director
James Gunn is back from the digital bed
and is giving us our clearest a smoking
gun
with two N's about the deepest mystery
among new rock stars open Case Files the
long-lost missing guardians of the
galaxy Easter Egg
now James Gunn has reawakened this
mystery by replying to a proposed answer
on social media with a cryptic score 50%
as in half of the Nerds weekend plans he
just snapped away let's break down what
this could mean what it tells us about
the upcoming Guardians vol 3 film and
see if we could just connect the dots on
this mystery with another new rockstars
tweet okay all the way back in 2018
James Gunn hinted on Twitter the big
Easter Egg has not been found not in
either vol 1 or vol 2 and at the time I
went ahead and reexamine the first
guardians film in a week when I
awkwardly had to Shaffer play I was
doing I dredged up a number of
interesting visual details I don't think
anyone had found before James Gunn did
make my life forever but said nope not
yet found the big Easter egg Gunn had
previously said that the Easter egg was
partially found but he would not confirm
until someone found the whole thing and
re-watched his movies 20 times it's
there it's already been partially
uncovered so you just need to find the
whole thing one of my favorite youtubers
MT decoded the coordinates for each new
planet more eggs and are the kiln
thanassis sanctuary the dark aster in
nowhere and using an alphanumeric
decoding system you can translate these
coordinates to the phrases
this is mom's cancer and Meredith quill
XOR Meredith quill BD Meredith quill of
course is a mother of Peter quill and X
or Biddy could refer to her ex-boyfriend
or baby daddy II go further d coatings
and combinations of letter groupings
with the other coordinates led to this
tweet that the egg Hunter tweeted to gun
this week this is mom's cancer this
isn't real X ego is cancer Meredith
quill loved the idea being that the
first guardians of the galaxy film back
in 2014 was already hinting at the big
twist in volume 2 Peter's mother
Meredith died from cancer given to her
by Peters real father ego and it was
this translation that gun graded as 50%
but here's the tricky part does 50%
referred to two of these four lines are
correct or this whole translation is
correct but only 50% of the full answer
well I'm betting on the latter because
back in 2018 guns tweet about the big
easter-egg said it had not been found
either in volume 1 or volume 2 so my
interpretation is that the big easter
egg is one that spans across both
guardians films of course volume 2 has
its own set of planet coordinate codes
the sovereign bear hearts contracts via
egos planet and ravager territory
there's all these numbers right here
ready to be looked at way too hard it's
right there is so much in this world
that really should be available to you
if you can just look hard enough for it
sadly depending on where you live things
like your access to a particular website
might be monitored or blocked well
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
episode and giving us some freedom and
privacy and security with our internet
usage expressvpn is a virtual private
network that encrypts your data to keep
it from being stolen or tracked and can
grant you access to blocked content like
many web sites and services are blocked
in different parts of the world and some
countries censor websites and don't let
you surf freely some things are even
more expensive online depending on where
you live airline ticket streaming
services it's not fair expressvpn allows
you to reroute your connection to a
server in a country of your choice
making geo restrictions that they gonna
pass expressvpn is also helpful for
preventing your online data from being
stolen or monitored without your
knowledge I like using it when I'm on
public Wi-Fi like at an airport or a
coffee shop to prevent those nosy
hackers from stealing my information I
don't want anyone to hack into my files
and see all the awful Wolverine puns I
have to slash out of my research
expressvpn servers operate at the
fastest speeds they have 24/7 customer
support and it's super easy to use just
fire up the app and connect with just
one click
it's a top-rated VPN provider rated
number one by tech radars seen it and
many more find out how you can get three
months free by clicking on the link in
the description box below expressvpn
comm slash new rock stars
again that's expressvpn comm slash new
rock stars so if we were to apply the
rule that volume ones code revealed the
big twist vol 2 we can look at the
volume twos code as a reveal for the big
twist of volume 3 what would that twist
be whoa gun has into another views of
volume threes gonna be all about rocket
so what do we know about rocket well we
should remind everyone that rocket is
not an earth racoons and are listed as
planet of origin as half world as it is
in the comics that listing also lists
strange anatomical features and later in
the kiln quill sees the surgical scars
of rockets cybernetic skeleton so guns
implication is that rocket is not just
from half world
there's some darker history behind his
cybernetic enhancements why he was
created and who created him is a mystery
further hinted at with a bunch of other
clues remind you how big and Impe that
hole inside you actually I said shut up
I know them scientists what made you
never gave a rat's ass about you hmm so
do the volumes you coordinates connect
to the mystery of rockets origins Oh
reddit user so wroclaw fiddled with the
numbers and came up with the following
translation biomedical clinic 89p13 half
world cave sea mission plan is to seek
IO Wyndham built math he's a smart
attack ICBM driver rash well actually
Windham could refer to Herbert Windham
aka the High Evolutionary from the
Marvel Comics Windham was kicked out of
Oxford for his radical genetic theories
he would experiment on animals
the big goal being evolving humanity
into advanced being he's actually
associated with Adam warlock the
genetically perfect gold cocoon fella
being incubated by Aisha in the
guardians to post-credit scene in the
comics it's the High Evolutionary who
gives Adam the sole gym that he keeps in
his head in volume 2 when Rocket swipes
through his tablet there's a bunch of
visible planet names including Terra
that's earth holla
that's a Kree planet from Captain Marvel
breslar and turma now term only appears
once in the Marvel Comics annihilation
conquest number one it's a Kree out
world where Adam warlock
is found in a stasis container this
storyline also ties in the High
Evolutionary I think this is all saying
that Rockets origin is intertwined with
the High Evolutionary and Adam warlock
rocket was clearly familiar with earth
before going there and infinity war an
endgame so what if this coordinates code
is pointing to Rockets origin as a
genetic and cybernetic creation by
Herbert Wyndham on half world to look
like an earth racoon for some evil plot
upon woman's return earth-like nuking it
with ICBMs letting the survivors evolve
this plot would be foiled and maybe to
escape windows wrath rocket piloted away
to Jupiter's moon of
oh and in volume three years later maybe
rocket will run back into the High
Evolutionary when he finds
evolutionary's masterwork Adam warlock
like perhaps not evolutionary now heads
up the Enclave that creates Adam for
Aisha and this whole genetics plot would
have implications beyond guardians three
like we're about to learn a lot about
everyone's genetic history with the
Eternals film the Eternals were created
on ancient earth as a genetic experiment
by the Celestials the same cosmic
entities as Isan the searcher in the
collector story in guardians volume 1
and quills father
ego who by the way I'm a believer
started as the disembodied brain from
the giant celestial skull that became
nowhere Celestials were mentioned by
nebula when describing for mere dominion
of Death
the very center of celestial existence
suggesting that the soul stones history
is connected with these ancient
celestial geneticists and by the way is
now being guarded by one of the biggest
eugenics obsessives Red Skull really may
be the big trend to face for will be
everyone doing these 23 in these seeking
genetic links with Celestials since
everyone knows Peter quill was able to
wield an infinity stone due to his ego
connection and Thanos as an eternal
might have also had that same kind of
DNA string and maybe and Guardians
volume 3 brackets will spearhead the
charge against this whole genetic purity
against figures like the High
Evolutionary and Adam warlock with the
message that one scars their
imperfections in the forged bonds with a
chosen family are the truer
representations of our souls what do you
think is the secret message of the
coordinates of volume to join our
discord server to go deeper into this
with us and really funn trying to code
break with our inner circle you can
access the discord by becoming a patron
today at patreon.com slash new rockstars
comment down below follow me at Navis
follow new rockstars social media and
subscribe dinner arc starts to follow us
on this wild goose chase by james gunn
to rewatch this movie's over and over
and over and over
well done gun
[Music]